all right our next speaker is amjad mad
from
repet uh come on up here we're going to
start off with uh what was Paul Graham's
quote about repet which one he's had a
few you know the one yeah he was like uh
repet is the next
Microsoft so Paul Graham who started why
combinator knows you guys pretty well
thinks that you guys are the next
Microsoft let's talk about why and not
so much from his perspective but you've
been working on this for a while you
have not focused on making money you
have not focused on all the you
basically have just been building a
product that really solves a problem for
customers where does that kind of
discipline and focus come from by the
way just before we get started I was so
engrossed by the uh talk with Howard he
I don't know if people realize but he
dropped some really serious Alpha uh
like a lot of what he talked about I I
sort of had to learn the hard way you
for example the one-on ones thing you
know I um I used to like get get so
drained uh just doing these therapy
sessions with everyone and it's was like
like is this why I started a company to
be a therapist I was like no I'm just
going to pay for coaches for all of you
and he can just go talk to coaches but a
lot of his uh a lot of what he had his
like really deep wisdom that it took me
a long time to I was basically like
vigorously nodding my head over there uh
which is really awesome uh so I hope I
can sort of match that but um yeah so uh
I think you know started uh working on
repet um or the idea that became repet
like back in college uh so I was doing
computer science uh at uh at University
back in Aman Jordan where I'm from that
was
20089 um and you know I I I thought that
um I could open a browser window and
start coding in the same way that I
could open a browser window go to my
email go to Google Docs turns out nobody
has built that I was like what what this
is crazy uh it's sort of like it's sort
of like finding $100 on the on the floor
of Grand Central Station it's like it's
impossible like why is this idea nobody
has worked on pretty quickly I found out
it's pretty hard that's why know
nobody's done that uh so that started
kind of my obsession with this idea of
like um why hasn't this been done before
and also what does it mean for the world
of actually software creation becomes as
accessible as creating a document as
posting a picture as all this stuff and
kind of the more I thought about it uh
the more the implications felt that it
was going to be really big like uh
if if we like on the order of the of the
creation of the printing press like the
printing press uh made it such that um
uh uh sort of reading and
writing became such a important things
thing
civilization um and you know all the
Democratic scientific all the
revolutions we've saw since since the
Gutenberg uh press and the you know
1500s or something like that we the
result of that right like we wouldn't be
where we are as a civilization if um we
wouldn't had this concept of you know
anyone can write and and you can
broadcast anyone can read it obviously
the internet brought it to the next step
well I would take it a step even further
right Shopify has this um Mantra of like
arm the rebels and they're talking about
arming e-commerce uh kind of smaller
businesses that want to go sell things
on the internet compared to the Goliath
of unsaid Amazon and you all though
almost feel like you are arming the
rebels of the Next Generation that
basically you're saying look learn to
code and then we will give you this
sandbox to go build anything that you
possibly can and like go take over the
world right what are you seeing in terms
of that first customers that come in
because I think part of what I'm so
impressed by your business is the
long-term thinking it takes to not just
go and say Hey I want you know the best
coders in the world to be able to go
onto this web page and be to code you
literally start with like well if we
need enough users we should teach them
how to code and then you're so far
Upstream that you can capture a lot of
the value on Microsoft which actually
going to be bigger than Microsoft uh if
we if we did it right right because
Microsoft uh ultimately relied on sort
of people already knowing how to build
things and how to code and what Howard
said about kind of not letting your VCS
dictate your growth rate that's
something that really benefited a l us a
lot because um you know the conventional
wisdom is that you built a good product
okay now you go sell it to companies uh
you figure out what the companies want
and you build for that but actually when
you go to Enterprises and you ask them
what they want they want the past they
don't want the future so you're sort of
it's a premature optimization that locks
you into the ways of the past and
doesn't really let you innovate
whereas what we wanted to do is actually
make the active software creation
radically different radically more
accessible more fun more interesting
more exciting faster and to do that we
had to go arm the rebels right we had to
go after the entrepreneurs the hobbyists
The Misfits the weirdos the students the
kids everyone that wasn't really
underserved by the Enterprise of op
Market um and um and so uh you know the
uh
um learning is just a means to an end uh
learning you know it could be fun to
just learn something for fun but people
learn a code in order to create
something and people want to create all
sorts of things with code you know from
art to science but also companies and
we've been so focused on this idea of
enabling entrepreneurs um and initially
it started on a small scale like you
know someone who build like a uh like an
app or something like that and that
would go viral maybe they they make a
few dollars off off of it or game but uh
just yesterday someone um uh sent me a
tweet um built this company called
Spellbook doai they just raised 11
million dollar and he's like I couldn't
have done it without a repli it allowed
us to move on a week by- week basis
create new MVPs and new prototypes and
get it in front of customers and he's
like I wouldn't be here without without
the the speed that this this gave me so
let's talk about artificial intelligence
um it is this call on new technology
even though it's not really new um it
seems to have caught the world uh by
surprise in some degree but also people
very quickly are wrapping their heads
around this is going to touch every
industry you all are heavily involved
both I think in terms of uh many of your
users are using this new technology uh
you all are doing everything from
hackathons to you know incorporating the
technology into your product um and then
you personally are very interested and
involved in terms of how this is going
to get regulated and and kind of some of
the pros and cons of current approaches
talk just about when you see something
that is so potentially fundamentally
shifting how do you even wrap your head
around what is the technology and like
what the implications are and how you
can adapt your business to it yeah I I
think the most important thing is to
really understand what the what the
technology does um from as close to an
ex exatic understanding of the
technology as possible right so for us
uh were focused on the active software
creation uh so what are the things that
actually make like so in the ideal
scenario you have an idea and you turn
that idea into a product or a piece of
software instantaneously right that's
you want a zero friction uh you know
zero milliseconds between idea and a
software right so okay what are the
steps that actually make make it so that
it's not zero milliseconds like it's
actually hour to week month whatever it
is um and there's all these complexities
that has to do with software with coding
things like that and so okay let's let's
take the active actually coding the MVP
or the Prototype a lot of that is just
boiler plate and it's just uh like
keystrokes to just uh help the computer
understand what's in your mind and a lot
of that could be automated and we did a
lot of classical automation of these
things like it's uh you know just
running script and um and and kind of
presetting up things and configuring a
lot of what makes repet special but I
always thought that the next level is
going to be about generating code and we
looked at it when I started the company
around
201617 and there were some interesting
experiments there actually using very
primitive language models but uh it
wasn't just there look at it again in
201819 it was kind of gpt1 2 it's like
oh that's an interesting thing but like
hey that generates like a lot of crappy
code and syntax doesn't compile or
whatever and then gpt3 happened I was
like okay it's now here and went kind of
all in in in 2020 21 released our first
generative AI product uh and 22 released
Ghost Rider our Flagship kind of code
generation product describe a little bit
about what Ghost Rider does uh Ghost
Rider has a lot of different modalities
and like the most simple way is like as
you're coding it actually predicting
what you're going to code next and just
doing doing it for you so it'll present
a suggestion similar to you know copilot
or Gmail kind of autocomplete kind of
background suggestion if you like it you
just hit tab if you don't like it you
just keep coding that's like a the main
modality people use it with the other
thing is if you actually want to stop
and construct a prompt uh to generate
like a function or a class or an entire
file you can do right click generate
code and actually give it a natural
language prompt and this goes to the
largest model that we have or on
offering so that we can generate an
entire file so this is this has to be
accurate the error rate needs to be
really low here if you want to talk
about any of these things if you want to
talk to the AI about what it just
generated if you want to ask the
questions about a code if you want to
plan a larger refactor change we have a
chat modality as well where you can like
go and have a um have a multi- turn
conversation with the AI so as you're
using these Technologies what's
interesting to me is the people who use
the te technology is very different if
somebody goes in and uses chat GPT and
it's you know uh your mother your friend
uh who maybe isn't as technical doesn't
have kind of the hacker mentality they
may ask it somewhat primitive questions
yeah when you put these tools in the
hands of people who have that hacker
mentality and have the skill set to
leverage them um they can move
incredibly quickly and they can really
stretch the limitations of what these
Technologies do can you tell us one or
two you know stories of things you're
seeing people do that even you who are
in this every single day and you know
have a good sense of the technology
you're like I cannot believe that people
are building this stuff so I I kind of
knew that this made coding easier what I
was surprised by is like one day this
guy built U 250k RR single guy on repet
business right uh in a few months um and
I started talking to him just trying to
understand how he's using the product
and he asked me a question uh and I like
to provide some support our customers as
well so he asked me a question was like
how do I do how do I lock a file and
make sure I'm not editing it while I'm
changing another file who's describing
git who's describing virtual control so
here's a guy who built a quarter million
dollars probably going to go to 1
million without knowing get you know and
the conventional wisdom is that oh you
need to learn all this you go to college
and you go through you know you go
through the motions you learn getting
all that and you start a project get in
it whatever all this doesn't
matters what matter is actually being
able to create a product and I asked him
like how are you able to do it and he's
like yeah just the AI and you know I'll
go back and forth with the AI um you
know I'll produce an error uh when the
error happens I'll either use Ghost
Rider or past it in chat CHT if I wanted
like a longer conversation and he uses
all the AI tools use Bard and chat and
repli Ghost Rider and everything um and
it it's just this iterative thing
between that person
the environment and the AI that actually
produces the code at the end and this is
a non quer that built a c start up with
code U and I didn't think that was
possible um is that really that
different like one of the jokes I think
if you go hang out with developers is
like it's all just Googling right you're
laughing because that is the joke right
um and so like to some degree are we
just now Outsourcing the Googling to the
AI and it's coming back with the code or
is there something different that's
happening yeah I I I think that's um I
think that's part of it I think what's
different is that Google doesn't talk
back to youh the AI actually can ask you
clarify uh clarifying questions can
provide feedback it's a lot more
personalized so it's like Google taking
to its ultimate conclusion the other
thing that I found interesting in how a
lot of these entrepreneurs are building
businesses
is uh you know thinking about generative
AI as a suite of tools that allow you to
build fundamentally new experiences we
have another s of founder uh priia who
um built this very interesting app that
basically takes a document and creates a
multimedia presentation from the
document uh and it is a pipeline of a
lot of different llms and a lot of
different generative tools such as audio
video and it's kind of obvious like you
want to put these things together but
the the extent to which people are
pipelining these tools to generate an
end creative product um is is really
surprising and makes me really excited
because we're we're getting to a point
where the the way to think about these
AIS is more like employees is more like
extensions of yourself it's more like
you know a team members that have
different Specialties that you can kind
of bring in depending on the task you
want to do and and that's really how the
people who Embrace these tools the most
use them as they kind of view them as
extension of their teams themselves you
all I think more so than any company
I've seen uh seem to hire your users or
hire your customers and this seems like
a great hack to really get high quality
people who believe in the mission talk a
little bit as to like what that process
looks like and do you think other
companies should be doing this more
often the process is that um
it's just so natur it's it's just so
organic like we uh sometimes like some
users Force themselves into the company
anyway where you sort of like they apply
they send an email to our jobs they
apply and whatever uh you know portal we
use for jobs they send emails to
individual uh employees they go to
contribute to to our to our open source
repos they'll do everything to be useful
and and suddenly we just see them as as
part of our team like okay I guess we're
going to let this 15-year-old kid like
you know join our team and you know a
lot of these kids stay for a long time I
mean um we've had we've had people join
when they're
18 uh and um and actually recently
someone left they were like 25 I was
like oh I kind of want to see other
things in the world
and and so it's was like okay you know
you've uh you you've earned your keep in
a way and the rich as as well right
think they made a lot of money uh you
know they got stock options at repet
like really really early on um and uh
it's awesome like seeing all these
hackers and and these people that
wouldn't otherwise be getting jobs like
get jobs at repet and a lot of them are
younger right that you guys are
specifically seeing because of kind of
the hacker culture and the product
itself and you're teaching people to
code but can it be replicated in other
businesses um
I think so so we've had we've had
instances where where look actually I
would say that everyone who almost
everyone who joins repet has used the
product and has loved the product and
loved the mission and the vision um and
so there's like some selection effect
that you can apply onto a lot of other
companies so I think the way
traditionally recruiting works is you
hire a recruiting team or recruiting
agency and they go out into the world
and they called email a bunch of people
and you kind of need to do that at least
early on but you know you have a lot of
low context people coming in and you
have to sell them on the vision they
have to actually believe it and and you
know some Seasons Executives will get
themselves to believe anything right to
you know they just want to be team
players but it's not as strong as when
you actually get people who believe and
I think you could do that by actually
just interacting with your customers all
the time uh with your partners uh and
you're going to be building these
relationships again that will make it
very organic to just hire from
so as you guys are building there's a
philosophy along with the actual product
itself uh there's been a rise of EC um
and it's this idea of just like
everything needs to accelerate rather
than have people tell us to slow down or
to over regulate or to um stop using
energy and you know we can go down the
line of all kind of the stupid arguments
that are being made in the
world how important is it for the
philosophy to be aligned with the
business and like how do you kind of
take that and incorporate into the
company culture because I think that
really if I talk to anyone at repet like
there's a it's like of course you work
at repet and that seems like a really
important part of the success of the
business this episode is brought to you
by aradon they are a brand new startup
led by a number of Silicon Valley
Legends who just raised $81 million to
build the future of Internet
infrastructure you're probably wondering
what that means let me explain there are
numerous new disruptive technologies
that are being adopted simultaneously
from blockchain to artificial
intelligence to zero knowledge
Technologies in order to ensure that
these Technologies thrive in this new
world we need new infrastructure and
that is where arine comes in they just
launched their first product line called
Tera flux which is a Bitcoin miner
powered by the world's first 4 nanomer
silicon chip technology these air cooled
singlephase and dual phase emerging
cooling miners have unrivaled speed and
efficiency they've Superior uptime and
they leverage a brand new innovation
called Energy tune that allows miners to
dynamically adjust the energy
consumption and Bitcoin hash rate based
on demand response needs of the
electrical grids aradine is an ambitious
company working on hard problems I'm
really impressed with them and if you
want to check out more you can go to
rodine.isfeld
today yeah so
um yeah I think there's like a radical
streak at repet in in what we're doing
which is um how do you take uh this sort
of Arcane art of software creation
that's been sort of created a lot of
wealth typically for a small population
of people typically in Silicon Valley
and actually make that so that anyone in
the world come PR spit in it and my
story where I came from and being able
to come here and become a Founder uh and
build this company that has a big impact
I think that story could be done a
hundred a thousand a million times and a
lot of the reason it hasn't been done is
because of artificial constraints
whether it's constraints on the tools
and how accessible they are and a lot of
times it's regulations it's uh certain
ways of doing things that perhaps not so
explicitly but sometimes times
implicitly is about um trying to
centralize power AI is where we see that
happening right in front of our eyes in
a very accelerated manner um where the
there there's like a clear power grab by
incumbents you know going to DC telling
them um hey I'm building something very
dangerous you should create a mode
around it so that I'm the only one
building it why would they say that I
mean it's kind of get let's just get
into it it's kind of comical like if if
I was if if I was like um if I'm like
making a Sci-Fi about like an evil
executive that wants to uh to do Rec to
capture it yeah I wouldn't go as absurd
as what we're seeing now with these CEOs
going in front of Congress and literally
saying saying that so before we get to
so naked yeah before we get to the
critiques of what they're doing let's
maybe put ourselves and for those that
don't know maybe some condex is helpful
so uh AI is huge uh there's a number of
companies probably three four or five of
them um who have been building various
components or Technologies around Ai and
rather than take the normal stance that
most technology companies have done for
ever and been like hey government you
stay over there we'll stay over here and
like you know leave us alone we'll leave
you alone these people are basically
going and knocking on the door in
Washington and they're saying regulate
me bro
reg me Daddy yeah which like if you kind
of think about it like what why would
you do that and so like what is their
thought process or or what is the
advantage what's the incentive for them
to go do
this I it's pretty obvious like I I kind
of like um look there are True Believers
that believe that AI is actually going
to kill everyone uh it's like a fringe
Theory started in like Berkeley they
wrote this block post of blog um site
called less wrong you can go read it
it's pretty insane
um they misnamed it it should have just
been wrong yeah just wrong just keep it
simple um but and I think those those
guys are True Believers I actually have
more respect for them then uh you know
they you know a lot of the a lot of the
people um that are actually asking for
regulation are using the same
arguments um and mark and dreon um
actually wrote this block post about AI
recently and um he kind of Drew
parallels to the period of um uh what's
the period where they banned alcohol uh
prohibition yeah the prohibition and he
he said that during the prohibition
there was actually like True Believers
and there were actually propers and so
what we're seeing a lot of the you know
Executives that are asking for
regulation are profiteering from the
natural fear that people have from AI
and the very potent message that some of
those True Believers have actually put
together over many many many years um
and the immediate the immediate need uh
to create a mode is because open source
is actually catching up at a rate that
never happened before you know typically
um sort of uh so typically there's a
lead time between software and open
source competitors uh in AI we've
actually that that lead time has been
shrinking uh and thanks to people like
Zuck who's emerged as a hero uh in the
situation with llama and llama code and
llama 2 um you know the leate time is
only a year or so or a year and a half
like you know I think gd4 level U open
source AI is probably llama 3 which I
know they're training right now as we
speak so uh there 's a there's a
impeding threat that would eat into the
bottom line of a lot of the the AI ug
ugly po right now so um and is this
compounded by um I saw a report recently
that cat gbt traffic is down for three
months in a row do you feel like um
there's kind of these short-term
pressures of obviously there's more of
these products on the market some of
them are open source some of them are
just close Source competitors and so
people kind of got through the threshold
hey we're the market leader at the
moment and they want to close the door
behind them and that's really what
they're doing yeah I mean I mean it's
pretty obvious like do you have another
explanation for it like I can't I can't
think if any like even if I want to be
extremely charitable like do you
actually believe that those CEOs are
actually like uh think they can kill
everyone in the world like existential
RIS they actually like if they thought
that why are you working on
it you know um and and so I just can't
like when I really try hard to kind of
think uh for an explanation that is
actually um as tradable as possible like
the best I can come up with if you're
actually worried about um say um like
effective AI on fraud effective AI on
critical infrastructure you would
regulate the applications of these right
so for example uh the US government can
say we can't apply AI to utility
companies managing electricity or water
whatever that that would be a reasonable
thing to to say or you have to kind of
meet a certain threshold for
applications in X Y and Z but what
they're asking the policy proposal that
open a anthropic and others have put
forward is that AI that has used x
amount of flops of compute should be
banned uh or should be banned from the
open and only a small group of people
should be able to train that and again
that's like a that's like a pretty clear
they're not even trying sort of like
pull the ladder type of approach and
look I I mean a lot of those people I
respect and are my friends we've worked
with them for a long time but my uh my
ultimate goal and the reason I'm working
at repet and I've done a lot of Open
Source I was part of the reactjs core
team react native and you know most of
my career has been done in open source
and I think open source is one of the
best tools for um freedom and software
self-determination and uh opportunities
for people to build businesses all over
the world um it just decentralizes the
opportunity in software in the same way
that that repet as well does um and um
an AI is the future of software it's
literally just software right um and I
if if the future software is
bottlenecked by these regulations then
they get that's going to be really bad
for the world we're we're
basically cutting off a potential much
better future you know the other day I
was um I was looking there was a This
research that come out after like a
multiple years of study showing that
metformin um uh during when you have
symptoms of coid if you take Metformin
it reduces your um your long coid uh
incidents by 40% the the thing that
generated the hypothesis for this is an
AI
so in in April 2020 uh a group of
scientists at at some University uh used
computer simulations and actually
natural language processing um to
understand how coid kind of works and
what potential interventions and they
hypothesize at the time that metformin
could be actually a good way to I think
based on protein synthesis whatever a
good way to to actually intervene and
turns out it's right AI is already
generating scientific hypothesis it's
generating scientific research we had
the you know Alpha fold with protein
folding it's amazing for the future of
healthcare for the future of Education
you and I are investors and and
synthesis they're working um on an AI
tutor AI tutors solve the two Sigma
problem the uh two Sigma Pro Bloom's two
Sigma problem is that what he found is
there's no education intervention in the
world that could be as good as
one-on-one tutoring uh so the whole
whole uh idea behind the startup is to
provide one- one tutoring for everyone
in the world and that really raises the
global IQ and so AI is the future of
software it's the future of humanity in
my opinion now back to the eak question
eak takes it a little further which is
uh the idea that we need to accelerate
all sorts of human progress and it's not
just AI it's also energy what's
happening in uh you know with the degs
in Europe and the antinuclear people uh
and and and the idea behind eak is how
do you build a coalition of
technologists and pro humans Pro
Humanity ultimately uh folks that
actually are countering the the sort of
degrowth uh death cult that has plagued
the the West uh and the idea behind it
is the kind of pural formulation is that
some people kind of divide the world
into develop versus developing and the
implicit assumption behind developed is
we already we're developed we're done
it's slim to cut the resources now uh
whereas the eak idea is like we're not
developed at all we're still primitive
as to where we could go as a
civilization which Camp are you in uh
take a guess um let's talk about
training data real quick um I recently
saw that a bunch of uh very well-known
bestselling authors got together and
they filed a class action lawsuit I
think against uh open Ai and chat gbt
and they basically were like hey you
took our work and used it as training
data among other other things uh and you
should have paid us for it um we've seen
Elon Musk really kind of lock down
Twitter uh it seems like Twitter was a
huge source of training data for these
models um where do you think it all
shakes out like will will anything on
the internet be fair game for the
training models will people have to if
they want to train a model go buy a
bunch of data how does this work out um
so here's where I'll show I'm not like a
total like anarcho capitalist free
radical um I I think that uh there's
probably uh um
some uh there's there's probably
something a government here could could
uh could could actually provide Clarity
on uh I think um at least uh the the the
problem as it happened with crypto is
when there's so much regulatory
uncertainty the pliers in the market
become kind of deranged and so no one
knows what to do uh there's a bunch of
lawsuits and maybe eventually we'll
we'll arrive at something but having
some clarity around around um what does
it mean and I think that there's like
Fair arguments on both sides those those
people affected by the training where
the value of their labor is uh
cheapened um because the output of their
labor went into the input of the of
training of this model it's actually
like a very like like there's a moral
argument there um that you you've taken
you've taken my labor
uh you obviously mixed it with your own
labor but but now you've reduced the
need for my labor by by by this new
model that you created um what we've
done at reflet is uh we we trained a
large language model for code um it's
the smallest most economical fastest uh
model for code it's a three billion
parameter model we train it in April
what we did is we trained in open source
data and uh we released the model as
open source because we thought that it's
the ethical thing to do if you train on
public data at minimum what you should
do is have your model be publicly
accessible publicly download
downloadable and then we had we wanted
to keep some Advantage for repet and so
the data that repet has and collects as
part of our service we trained a model
that was 50% better uh and that we kept
for our users our customers right I
think that's a fair trade if you're open
Ai and you're training all of the data
of the internet you should at least
contribute something to the internet as
as part of the as open source and maybe
there's some Advantage you keep for your
company and this is the kind of the the
value you keep the last thing I want to
talk about is AI agents um I think when
people first kind of realized we're
going to be able to do this there was an
it felt like every single day multiple
things were going viral on Twitter where
it was just like holy look what
this can do what do you think is
actually like commercial uh available
maybe 5 years from now versus hackers on
the internet you know make it order them
food or or kind of do cool things but
there might not actually be like
business opportunity there I actually
think agents are going to be huge um but
um like a there's like a lot of
infrastructure to build we actually
three or four months ago took a pause on
a lot of the AI features we're building
because we just realized that the amount
of hacks that you have to do to get
anything working was just like growing
exponentially and the AI was getting
worse over time
and so we took a step back and what we
do at rep is build abstractions so we
build an abstraction we call it a chat
service not very inspiring name but
basically uh it figures out it's like a
multi-component system where there's
like an intent detection layer without
getting too much into the details but I
think a lot of people are just thinking
about one model and maybe you
recursively kind of prompt this model
and this is an agent but what I'm saying
agents are going to be a society models
there's going to be uh there's going to
be different models at every part of the
chain doing different things and some of
these models are going to be hypers
specialized and trained to be more
agentic and maybe at the core there's
the mega models the GPT 4 the Geminis
GPT 5 whatever it's going to be but it's
a system and I think a lot of
researchers the way think about AI is
they think about just a model and the
end to end learning of the model as
Engineers we need to think about systems
and to think about systems mean that you
would need different tools for different
part of components of this of the system
so I think agents are coming um I would
probably I probably think by next year
we're going to have pretty compelling uh
use cases both in the consumer and
Enterprise side and on the software
creation side um but I would probably
give it another uh year two probably 25
26 uh a lot of our lives are going to be
touched by AI agents uh such that you
know everything will whenever you're
interacting with robots today it's kind
of sucks like when you get when you're
on the phone and kind of press one for
customer service whatever this this
sucks it'll get a lot better you'll be
able to just talk to it um a lot of the
back office stuff is going to get
automated um and uh and so I think I
think everything in the economy will
just like get behind the scenes better
but also a lot of consumer interactions
will be a lot more delightful it is
funny that you call a phone tree and it
you know asks you to talk now or you
just press zero a bunch of times and you
feel like you hacked The Matrix a little
bit right and then they just like Loop
you back and you're like all right
there's they're smarter than me um how
can uh how can businesses leverage repid
or or like how can some of the founders
who are here who um either have
businesses or thinking about certain
businesses leverage the product so I I
don't think we're ready to run entire
businesses on repet yet but I what I
will say if you're if you're starting
from scratch I I would just do inter
repet like if you're starting a product
from scratch you would move 10x Faster
by doing a repet uh if you're a bigger
company you want to start to adopt it
think about a microservice or a back
office task or internal tool or a
slackbot or whatever that could be an
isolated thing that people can spin up
really quickly that uh uh that way you
can sort of start adopting it it can
also be helpful for internal prototyping
sharing between between people inside
the company um but yeah definitely if
you're starting if you're a fan of
starting from scratch like I used to
like for the first time I'm like
comfortable saying it would be a bad
decision not not to do it on ret so uh
because recently we just um released our
deployments feature and so you can
actually deploy and scale up to Infinity
if you'd like uh any kind of application
so I think it's uh it's really wise to
start there thank you so much for
this